then also with the big hit comes people
that aren't so happy as well if you say
that you're a supporter of Donald Trump
or oh yeah people are mad about that
yeah you know I don't give up
yeah I mean is that how you do it
everybody has well everybody had to
choose for themselves according to their
own conscience who they thought was the
lesser of two evils you know everybody
chose that so I'm not gonna put anybody
down who didn't vote like me this is
America it's a free country and you know
when you weigh it all together you know
I think I just felt like we needed a
whole new thing all the way bottom to
top yeah Roseanne Barr is not racist
it's it's absolutely ridiculous the
whole purpose of the Roseanne show was
the show blue collar workers and they
had black friends and gay friends and
blah blah